today we're gonna be talking about a
subject near and dear to my heart that
subject is 50 shape this week we're
gonna be talking about books now I want
to give you a list of my recommendations
and since it's the new year and we
always say new year new you I want to
come up with a theme around that this
list will not only serve as a foundation
for you to understand yourself better
but also those around you ever since
medical school I've realized I'm a
better auditory learner I can be
multitasking and still taking all the
points that I'm listening to in fact I
told you this before I used to stream
all of my lectures multiple times
instead of sitting and reading the notes
now my go-to way to get these audiobooks
is through audible in fact audible is
the sponsor to this video and I'll be
giving you guys a 30-day free trial if
you stay tuned to the end of this video
alright let's jump right into it I'm
gonna be talking about five books that I
think will make you a better all-around
you what everybody is saying by Joe
Navarro now I love the catchy title in
this book what everybody is saying okay
I see what you did there this is a book
covering human body language but I think
this is very important because most of
human communication is actually
nonverbal Joe Navarro is actually an
ex-fbi agent and he talks about all
these unique tips that you can use to
read people from across the room or even
someone you're interacting with even the
smallest body parts eyelids cheeks
fingers the names Sherlock Holmes when I
read this book for the first time it
shocked me I love people watching I
started understanding what was going on
in each situation without even needing
to hear what they were saying the entire
body gives us a better picture than just
the face and I'll use an example from
the book where if you look at two people
having a conversation and you look at
the direction of where their feet are
pointing
speaks volumes about how much they're
enjoying that conversation if you see
two people sitting next to each other
and one person's feet are pointing away
from that person they're ready to get
out of that conversation Joe even goes
as far as to give you simple tips to
change your posture to allow you to
express authority to build trust with
somebody else if you put your hands
completely in your pockets that's a very
passive submissive pose now if you want
to exemplify a little bit of confidence
all you have to do is take your thumbs
out and that just makes your body
language speak with more thorne
influence the psychology of persuasion
by Robert Cialdini PhD I love reading
books on influence and it's not because
I want to manipulate somebody people
often think that influence carries a
negative connotation I think it's more
manipulation that carries the
connotation manipulation by definition
is a shrewd or devious way to influence
somebody for your own advantage if a
patient walks into my office they have
high cholesterol high blood pressure and
they don't exercise it's my job to
influence them to begin an exercise
regimen it doesn't mean that I'm
manipulating them for my own advantage
now in everyday life we not only need to
be very good at influencing people at
our jobs whether your doctor influencing
your patients or a teacher influencing
your students we also need to be aware
of those who are trying to influence or
manipulate us it's just a matter of
luring him out one of the concepts this
book breaks out very well is something
known as the contrast principle and it's
something that salespeople utilize all
the time in order to get you to spend
more money I'm a salesperson and you're
coming into the store to buy a suit
I'll get you committed to buying this
400 dollar suit and then I'll offer you
an $80 sweater which is a pretty
expensive sweater but it won't look as
expensive because you've already spent
$400 wow that's messed up the
influential mind by Talley Seurat if you
want someone to understand where you're
coming from it's gonna take a lot more
than facts and figures oh I like that
that was a good most people are
influenced by emotions rather than facts
and figures
you can see this right now on the news
cycle when somebody starts talking to
your primitive brain they do a much
better job at influencing your thoughts
and even your actions when your mind is
stressed it's much more easily
influenced and we see this after
horrible terrorist attacks like
September 11th it takes one person to
start running in order to get hundreds
to do the same because in that stress
state they're more likely to be
influenced I think the real gem in this
book is that it teaches you how to
communicate with somebody that disagrees
with you the way you do that is you
establish a new concept that doesn't
necessarily disagree with their
viewpoint but does agree with yours once
you find that sort of common ground it
can facilitate that conversation and
allow you to exert your influence if I'm
trying to encourage a parent to
vaccinate their child and they happen to
be anti vaccine instead of going back
and forth and arguing about the
side-effects of vaccines I introduced a
new point where we can both agree that
the disease of the vaccine prevents like
measles is a bad disease if the parent
agrees with me we have a much higher
likelihood of seeing I and I and
agreeing on getting a vaccination for
their child
public speaking for success by Dale
Carnegie we all need to improve how we
speak in public to be an effective
communicator to share your story to
influence people to be a better person
yourself you need to be able to be a
better public speaker Dale Carnegie
gives you some really simple steps that
anyone can follow in order to be a
better public speaker one of those steps
that I take to heart and use in all of
my speeches is the idea of verbalizing
your speech or your talk before even
doing it that way your brain can recite
the information get used to saying it
you'll probably stumble and that's okay
because you're practicing but you have
to practice it talks about really great
speakers how they presented their
speeches what words they used why
certain speeches were more effective
than others and that really goes a long
way in order for you to communicate your
ideas flow the psychology of optimal
experience by me Holly
I'm sure even though this book is called
the psychology of optimal experience
it's basically a book about happiness
this is an evolving field of psychology
known as positive psychology and this is
one of the first books I've read on the
subject and I've become obsessed in
medicine we always look at the negative
symptoms we talk about depression
anxiety bipolar disorder but positive
psychology focuses on the positive
aspects of life what is flow when you're
playing basketball when you're rock
climbing when you're playing an
instrument you're putting in a lot of
effort and generally for human survival
sake at least when we put an effort
it's an done so in order to get
something in return
whether that's financial return sexual
return that feeling you feel when you're
climbing a mountain playing an
instrument playing basketball is called
flow it's a very self fulfilling
authentic happiness that you feel when
people look at my Instagram or YouTube
channels they always comment on how
happy I look and they say that they
don't believe that I'm always so happy
or that they want to know how I'm always
so happy I think flow is a great reason
of why I'm happy flow explains that in
order to feel happiness to get in that
intrinsic joy in life you constantly
need to set these little achievable and
meaningful goals for yourself whether
we're talking about cleaning the house
in a certain amount of time or reading a
certain amount of books in a given year
a great paradox that this book addresses
is that we don't spend our free time
well most people can't wait to leave
work they can't wait to retire but when
they do they actually become more
unhappy more anxiety sets in when you
are not activating your mind to reach
goals and set challenges for yourself
like you are every time you're at work
your mind fills that empty space with
anxiety when you have anxiety that leads
to more problems more depression when
you're at work and you're constantly
setting new goals and new obstacles for
yourself you're able to reach those
goals and therefore feel that reward
system kicking in boom there
you have it those are my five titles to
help you become an all-around better you
I've listened to all of these titles
using audible and now you can sign up
for a 30-day free trial and get one of
these books for free using www Mike
that's a UD IB le dot-com slash do ctor
mi ke or you can even text five hundred
five hundred the word doctor Mike
that's right do ctor mi ke you get your
30-day free trial and you can read one
of these bad boys and as always stay
happy and healthy go to www.hsn
but once you've already spent $400 on
the suit eighty dollars doesn't seem so
much it seem like so much I even listen
to audio books on the gym on the gym
what does that mean on the gym I sit on
top for the gym and I read
[Music]